- Hello and welcome everybody,
thank you for coming.
So yeah, I'm Chris Bingham.
I'm the AWS Ambassador
and Country CTO for
Switzerland at Fujitsu.
And at Fujitsu we're applying
AI to real business issues
that are beyond just code generation,
which we've heard a lot about today
and this week at re:Invent,
with the aim of aiding skill
and accelerating skilled people such
as supply chain managers.
So what challenges do
supply chain managers face?
Well, not being one myself,
I did the 2025 thing
and I asked an AI and
it told me all of this.
The answer, lots and varying challenges,
but I feel they can be
summarized with three key words,
volatility, disruption and transformation.
Anybody else experiencing those things in
their work these days?
It's a bit of a common theme, isn't it?
So overall supply chain
management involves working
with a lot of rapidly
shifting data across many,
many dimensions and sources
from suppliers, from
customers, from customs
and regulators, from
manufacturing through to sales,
and every business unit in between.
And of course, this
kind of high complexity,
high dimensionality scenario
is exactly where AI excels.
Particularly, where AI works
with experienced professionals,
domain experts who can wield AI
to achieve positive business impacts.
And creating positive
impacts through data and AI
is at the core of Fujitsu's uvance
decision intelligence offerings.
A key tenant of uvance
decision intelligence is
to enable your teams through data
and AI by providing solutions
which act as companions
supporting you in your work
through the combination
of Fujitsu's technical expertise
and your domain expertise.
This approach delivers high
quality decisions at pace
with the aim of creating positive business
and social impact.
And in this spirit, our teams
applied their domain knowledge
to create a solution to help
supply chain management.
Our first generation solution was built
to aid supply chain managers
through automation and AI.
It leveraged AI agents
to intelligently help
with balancing inventory
and crucially with managing
adverse effects and disruptions.
For example, this screenshot
shows the supply chain effects
of an earthquake which
occurred in January, 2024.
In this case, this real world
case, our customer was able
to quantify the impact
of this earthquake on the supply chains
and begin mitigation within two hours.
Their competitors by comparison
had to work around the clock
for three days to get to the same point,
which sounds wonderful.
However, this version
of our solution faced
some technical challenges.
In a nutshell, speed.
Agentice AI, like all other uses of AI,
is only effective when
it's attuned to reality.
And here our first generation
approach was limited.
Lacking a single cohesive platform
for managing agent life cycles,
the very pieced together
architecture which we had
hindered our ability to adapt agents
to changing circumstances.
Unchecked this would lead to agent drift,
agents moving away from the
business context over time,
resulting in the relevance
and quality of their responses degrading.
Leading to negative impact
on the business outcomes our
customers could achieve.
So how did we build a
solution which could rise
to this challenge of agent drift?
Well, we're at re:Invent, so
naturally enough with AWS,
specifically Bedrock AgentCore provides
that single coherent platform
for managing our agent's life cycles.
AgentCore replaced the mishmash
of components at the heart
of our AI agents with a
single joined up platform.
This simplified architecture
diagram illustrates
how AgentCore integrates
into our uvance SCM solution.
Agent Core runtime provides,
naturally enough, the runtime
environment for all of our AI agents.
AgentCore Gateway handles
the integration of all
of the supply chain data sources
and tools which those agents need.
Whilst AgentCore identity
manages centralized access control for all
of those agents against all of
those tools and data sources.
And last but by no means
least, AgentCore Observability
provides deep insights into the how
and the why of AI agent performance.
And that final piece,
AgentCore Observability is the linchpin to
how we addressed the
challenge of agent drift
by creating yet another AI.
Yes, more AI on top of AI.
The Guardian Agents, as we
call it, the Guardian Agent,
is tasked with guarding against drift.
It works to identify cases
where our SCM agents' responses
have started to degrade
and then acts to correct
that drift based on both
agent core observability data
and supply chain manager's feedback.
The uvance SCM UX includes opportunities
for supply chain managers
to provide qualitative
feedback on the business
performance of the agents.
This enables uvance SCM
to capture any shifts in
that business performance independently
of any technology metrics.
The guardian agent can then combine
that business performance feedback
with observability data from AgentCore,
most especially the chain
of thought data like the
example which we see here,
to work out where in that chain
of thought the agent has started to drift.
And in doing so, formulate
modifications to the prompts used
for that agent.
These prompt updates are then
stored in a central DynamoDB
prompts table and utilized for next time
that drifting agent is called.
This means for automated analysis of
and reaction to agent drift is triggered
by human feedback.
By supply chain managers
identifying insufficient
business context fit implicitly
through their feedback,
creating a human-centric approach
to evolving the AI
agents, which is supposed
to help the humans.
So with that, I'm now gonna
show you a quick video
demonstration of uvance SCM.
And hopefully we'll get the audio.
- [Narrator] I'd like to show
you a real time demonstration
(indistinct).
When the project started,
(indistinct) had 1,000 people
working in the global (indistinct).
Their resources were aged
and many veteran workers
were starting to retire in three years.
Reducing the required resources
was one of their most pressing challenges.
Their most labor intensive
task was (indistinct).
They had about 50 to 100 workers
at each plant (indistinct).
Because their systems were silent,
they had to manually
calculate the inventory
to identify excess and
(indistinct) using exceptions.
One person could cover
up to just 10 minutes,
so they needed 1,000
people to (indistinct).
So we've made this dashboard.
Now all they have to do is
(indistinct) notifications
when the system (indistinct).
This dashboard is now used
by company top management
and also (indistinct).
Here in this view you can
see the (indistinct) trend
(indistinct), factoring in
it's peculiar production
sales client.
I haven't seen many other
company that can do the same.
The yellow dot indicates the
time (indistinct) origin.
The red dot indicates (indistinct).
And the purple path shows the opportunity
to be lost in a (indistinct).
The blue line shows the optimal inventory
according to (indistinct).
In just two months the
AI generated (indistinct)
of less than 10%.
(narrator drowned out by static)
So by just following this blue line,
the customer can not only
reduce the cost associated with
(indistinct), but also
increase the revenue
while holding the loss
of sales opportunities.
The value generated so far is
significant, as you can see,
but if we utilize AI agents on top of it,
we can aim to have the necessary resources
again (indistinct).
(narrator drowned out by static)
As this view is just for
demonstration, (indistinct).
(narrator drowned out by static)
So now both agents are
processing the costs.
(narrator drowned out by static)
This job description (indistinct).
The AI agents, the (indistinct).
This (indistinct) the
concept of Fujitsu uvance,
which is to (indistinct)
business model (indistinct).
(narrator drowned out by static)
Most companies can never
recalculate the (indistinct),
such as which suppliers are
important to (indistinct).
(narrator drowned out by static)
Is extremely difficult
without (indistinct).
(narrator drowned out by static)
This particular estimate is
able to identify (indistinct).
(narrator drowned out by indistinct)
- Okay, so to summarize,
our customers have seen meaningful boosts
to their SCM team's efficiency
from deploying uvance SCM,
leading to significantly
more rapid responses
to incidents within their supply chain.
And thanks to Bedrock
AgentCore's capabilities,
we've been able to
accelerate the integration
of new data sources such
as may come when you have a new supplier
by roughly an order of magnitude.
And these benefits together
improve your resilience,
both against everyday issues
and major adverse events.
And with that, if you'd like
to learn more about uvance SCM
or any of the other solutions we offer,
please do come and visit us.
We're at booth 1851, which
is roughly in that direction.
Or please connect with us
online via the QR code here
and we will happily arrange
for our experts to come
and meet with you after
re:Invent at your convenience.
Thank you very much for your time.
And do enjoy the rest of your re:Invent.